for years I went on radio for free
talking about economics who am I coming
up against someone from the Ia that is a
think tank there's a group of think
tanks which are sort of near Westminster
they talked about as a tough and Street
think thanks they're funded by
billionaires yeah and they give them
sensible names such as you know
taxpayers Alliance Institute for
economic Affairs billionaires paying
money for people like me to go on TV and
radio and say whatever you do don't tax
Rich because it's bad for you so a lot
of rich people pay a lot of money to
tell you that it's bad for you and what
they want people to hear when I say tax
the rich is we want to taxt you we want
to taxt your n we want to taxt your mom
and you know that's you know this is the
why it's become unpopular